yelling is with us in taxes hi Dylan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show what's
going on Dave better than I deserve man
how can I help
well I'll start off by saying I've
always been a saver
my parents are big savers they followed
your baby step plans years ago they told
me to Nollan on my own I should follow
it but uh like I told the lady who
answered my call I'm pretty stubborn I'm
gonna need you to tell me this you know
Dylan you got to do this get it in my
head I'm very fortunate I do very well I
have about 800 to a thousand dollars
extra a month that I put towards my
debts after minimum payments and
everything it's split amongst my savings
account a finance TV big TV a car
payment and my student loans when was it
you listen to your parents how I when I
listen to that one when you took out a
loan on a big-screen TV I loved that TV
not a smart decision I know but I want
my TV and I don't have any issue paying
for it all right you had an issue paying
for it cuz you couldn't you put it on
that but yeah all right well yes sir
so I take about that eight hundred
thousand dollars a month and I really do
pad my savings I'm well past step one
into step two but I it's a psychological
thing I love having a padded savings
account that's where the most of it goes
okay and then I take about the extra go
ahead I said okay go ahead
you're fine okay yeah you have a plan
you have a system and so how much is in
savings right now it's about eight grand
okay and how much debt do you have on
the TV and the other stuff the TV has
about twenty one hundred on it no
interest the cars at about eighteen
grand and the student loans total to
about 23,000 okay and what do you what's
your household income I make about 3,800
a month after taxes how old are you I'm
going to be 24 on the six okay
and what does it you want me to tell you
well baby step two you know you say I
should
take all that disposable income and I
should put it towards the small debt
first and then I should go to the next
smallest and the next smallest right now
I take about the extra eight hundred
that I have I understand what you're
doing I understand what you're doing
what's your question my question is
should I take all that money and follow
baby step two like you say and and and
just knock the TV out and why would I
not tell you to do the system that I've
told millions of people to do well it's
you know I don't feel overwhelmed about
my debt and I you should how like you're
24 years old you make $45,000 a year and
you're broke you're deeply in debt and
somehow you figured out that this is all
okay you ought to be very afraid you'll
weigh too much on your car and you're
you're stupid but TVs absolutely
insanity yeah you ought to be upset I
wish I could get you upset and then
you'd probably do something about it